Do you think of Trump winning the US election?
Do you wanna know? I'll go first
because I think that you should shut up as a man about this
cause I don't think that men really understand the true impact
of how it feels. And I don't really think it matters on a global scale
because I think that either party is gonna commit genocide.
But I do think
the most troubling aspect to me is the message it sends to men.
The message it sends to men is if you're a rapist,
if you're liable
and have been held liable in civil court for sexual assault,
that you can become one of the most powerful men in the world.
We've seen on Twitter the last few days what that has created,
which is men saying, your body,
my choice. A man saying,
I saw a woman crossing the road in front of me while I was driving
and I put my foot down on the accelerator because rights,
you don't have them anymore as a woman.